hey everyone it's Ryan I'm recording
this late at night in Boston from Josh's
bedroom wait that didn't really sound
right
oh say Sean's bedroom
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me
hey everyone its Joshua I'm recording
this late at night in Boston last night
we kicked off the minimalism documentary
tour with the film's world premiere in
New York City and it was awesome I just
want to say thanks real quick to
everyone who came out everyone who
waited in the rain you all are wonderful
after the screening we recorded a live
version of our ask the minimalist
podcast with the film's director Matt
dia Vela which we're going to share with
you in a moment but first just a quick
note as you probably know our entire
tour is completely sold out so thank you
all to everyone who's attending but for
those of you who wanted to get a seat
but you didn't get one in time don't
worry there will still be 10 tickets at
the door of each theater and those are
first-come first-serve so you can show
up once everyone has a seat then you can
purchase your tickets and and get into
one of our live events you can find our
entire tour schedule at the minimalists
comm a slash tour we're gonna be at a
bunch of cities Boston Washington DC
Miami
Dallas Dayton Ohio Chicago Seattle San
Francisco then we're gonna be in Los
Angeles Salt Lake City Missoula Montana
and Toronto but also remember the film
is going to be in about 400 theaters
across the United States and Canada yes
that's right it will be in Canada you
can find your closest theater at
minimalism a film dot-com
just click on see the film okay that's
all we really hope you enjoy this
special LIVE episode of the minimalists
podcast well hello ladies and gentlemen
welcome to our first ever live edition
of the minimalist podcast I'm Joshua
fields Melbourne and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and for the first time we have a guest
on our
Podcast Wow honored Machiavelli I'm not
a minimum the minimalist now well you
are aiming close though and and so you
all are the first audience to get to see
this this version of the film so we yes
yes thank you and you all did an awesome
job this sold out really quickly and so
they gave us the the bigger theater and
y'all sold that out so this has been
amazing and we we had a Film Festival
version of the film that went around
through a bunch of film festivals and
some of you may have seen that it was an
appreciably different version from the
film and we fought with Matt repeatedly
about all the changes that were made
between that film in this film and I
think all of our fighting finally made a
he pushed back on us a lot basically but
it made it made a much better film than
we had before we had a really good film
and I feel great about the perspectives
that that we were able to put out there
and really share a bunch of different
recipes in hopes that you got value and
from at least some of them and I know
that your life probably doesn't look
exactly like any one of the lives in
there when I first discovered minimalism
my life didn't look like Colin writes it
didn't look like Leo's it didn't look
like any of the the minimalist who I
admired and I knew I wanted to create my
own recipe for minimalism and that was
our hope was to deliver that to you in a
way that made minimalism a little bit
more palatable a little bit more
approachable and so we'd love to know
what kind of questions you have either
about the film or about minimalism or
about Ryan's haircare products we have a
microphone set up somewhere I believe
there's that right somewhere oh it's
over here
there's one here and I think there's
another one over there as well so feel
free to step out there's only one over
here is there one on this side as well
oh is there on both sides so feel free
to step up to either side oh yes thank
you for breaking the ice like it always
takes one person they kind of like it
the questions going did you say your
name and whatever your question is
Melissa authority Schwartz and I was the
first person who made a question in the
phone in the first podcast so also nice
to meet you in person thanks for going
declutter and gradually versus doing it
once but I just wanted to thank you
awesome film
great message and just keep up the
amazing work oh thank you very much
thank you
oh yeah you're more than welcome to come
here and give compliments too it was
easy question I see someone with a
question and she looks come on positive
no feel free to like form a line or
queue as it were you just pull it out
there you neither was i until I said I
was I just had a question I was really
appreciative as a mom of three that you
added the parenting [ __ ] sure is there
the wife of the minimalist is like
what's the balance with three small
children I get that there is the dad of
six and I just want to see how you do
that yeah sure real life well I I can
tell you this so I became a parent by
proxy last year and and so the life you
saw in this film which we started
filming toward the end of 2013 and most
of it was 2014 the life that I have now
is very similar in most ways but also
appreciably different in some ways as
well so I have almost three-year-old kid
and it's it's an interesting perspective
in my life because I noticed that
because I had simplified my life prior
to that it made that transition into
that world a lot more simple right
but what I've picked up or quite a few
things is the lessons that I've learned
well little kids don't know that yet or
even other kids or most adults don't
know the lessons that I've learned
through the process I mean I can look
back I'm 34 years old now I can look
back at my 27 year old self with a
certain amount of disdain I can just
sort of nod my head and and and wonder
what I was doing when I was 27 and all
of these weird decisions I was making
but of course when when I'm looking at
Ella she's two and a half years old and
I'm trying to just teach her
basics like delaying gratification right
and and it's incredibly difficult but
there are there are lessons in
ephemerality that I've that I've learned
over the last several years meaning
learning how to enjoy the moment I was
talking to a reporter about this the
other day every morning I have some
pretty bad issues with my back I have to
do these these interesting exercises
with a balloon in the morning that helps
with with some back pain that I have but
anyway afterward I have a balloon that's
blown up and so in the morning I'll go
into Ella's room and I will give her the
balloon and she's really really grumpy
in the mornings and when I when I give
her the balloon she's instantly happy
and and of course what happens when you
give a two-and-a-half-year-old a balloon
it pops a couple minutes inevitably it's
going to pop almost every morning and it
upsets her every morning but over the
course of several months of doing this
she's learned the to appreciate the fact
that I need to enjoy this well it's
right here in front of me now the first
few times 1/2 and she freaked out and
she started crying obviously and it was
the end of the world but as time went on
she realized okay this is going to pop
hey I need to take care of it and B I
need I need to enjoy this now as it's in
front of me and let's play with it well
let's have fun with it
let's also realize that you know what
this this isn't going to last forever
and to me that was a perfect metaphor
for everything else in life and so I
guess what I'm saying is really what
what I've realized is that is that our
kids are watching us and we can say
whatever we want to say about you should
do this you should do that but when they
see the Y they see your actions behind
what you're doing it's far more
important than you know telling someone
what they should do in fact I'm still at
34 someone tells me you should do
something it's my inclination to do the
exact opposite of whatever they tell me
I should do and I think kids are the
same way and they really see four more
actions I don't have any kids so it's
really easy for me to give advice now I
will share something that an audience
member told me
at one of our events where someone asked
a similar question and I'm like you
don't want you know a single guy with no
kids like giving you advice and someone
stepped up and they said let me tell you
what I do with my with my kids I hate
telling my children no I just hate it so
I try to tell them as yes as often as I
can
and the example that she gave was like
her little five year old daughter would
come home with an art project something
she colored up and she would go to her
mom and be like hey mom look you know
look at this great picture that I
colored in school today can we hang it
on the refrigerator and of course it's
already like you know art overflowing
the front of the refrigerator social say
yeah we absolutely can't put that on the
refrigerator let's walk over and let's
pick which piece of art we're gonna take
off the refrigerator and replace it with
so they will go over to the refrigerator
they she will the daughter will choose
which piece of art she no longer wants
to display and then the walk over to the
trash together and they get rid of that
art project very similar with toys it's
it's like if they ask for a toy and it's
appropriate and they have the money for
it then the mom will say yeah I would
love to get that for you which toy would
you like to donate and give to another
child I thought that was a really good
way to kind of face those questions yeah
I also don't have any kids but I guess
what I would say is that it's never
perfect I think a lot of times we have
this ideal of what life is gonna be like
you want to be a minimalist especially
in the very beginning stage when I
became a minimalist I was like this is
gonna be this is gonna change my life
and everything's gonna be perfect from
here on out and I think the one thing
that you start to realize is that like
these guys were saying like in the film
it is simpler I think it's easier to
navigate a lot of the obstacles that do
come into your life but it's not perfect
and I imagine when you have kids even
being in a relationship there's
compromises that you need to make you
need to decide what's gonna work for the
group as opposed to what's just gonna
work for yourself I think you were next
you can just you got it hi my name is
Hollis thank you for this wonderful
documentary was a great experience
thanks for coming out
many of the people in this room are
concerned about how to bring minimalism
to their children I respectfully suggest
that part of the problem our generation
is facing is bringing minimalism to our
parents one of the most harrowing
experiences I faced in my life after my
mom died was excavating our childhood
home was like an archaeological dig for
my depression-era mother who saved
everything she was she was healthy she
was solvent but we found like 20 pairs
of rusted
scissors ten tennis racquets that hadn't
hit a ball in 40 years
we found a not small bag of adult human
teeth none of which belong to anybody in
our family I'm kidding a harrowing
experience and as an aging boomer myself
I'm just out of curiosity how many
people in this room are over the age of
60 there are four people in this room
over the age of 60 and you guys will
face possibly the same experience we
faced when we bite the dust unless we
get wise and deal with it ourselves
living with clutter is a horrible life
and it's also a horrible legacy so I'd
like to ask your experience working with
older people and how the boomer
generation is facing up to the way the
Peter Pan generation we grew up in an
age of extreme abundance and we went
from sex drugs drugs and rock and roll
to just too too much of everything you
know one generation from Ozzie and
Harriet to Ozzy and Sharon so I'd really
be interested in your take on how
minimalism can be brought to an aging
population so we don't leave our kids
with a horrible legacy of too much stuff
well thank you great question
so we touched on a little bit in the
film in 2008 my mother moved to to
Florida to finally retire because that's
what you do when you live in Ohio or New
York you move to Florida and a few
months after she moved down there she
found out she had lung cancer and I
spent a lot of time with her that year
she was going through chemo and
radiation and when she passed I I
realized I needed to make one last trip
down to down to Florida and this time it
was to deal with her stuff so I flew
from Dayton Ohio down the st. Pete Beach
Florida and and when I arrived I got to
Mom's tiny one-bedroom apartment I found
about three apartments worth of stuff
crammed into that tiny one-bedroom
apartment now she wasn't a hoarder there
were no teeth in her freezer but she
owned a lot of stuff right she had 65
years worth of accumulations walked into
her living room it was stuffed with big
antique furniture and old paintings and
more doilies than I could count and her
kitchen was stuffed with plates and cups
and bowls and utensils and her bathroom
was stuffed with enough hygiene products
to start a small beauty supply business
and her linen closet it looked like
someone was running a hotel out of her
linen closet I was stuffed with
mismatched bath towels and beach towels
and dish towels and bed sheets and
blankets and quilts and then I went
through her bedroom now can anybody tell
me why mom had 14 winter coats stuffed
into her bedroom closet
some still had tags on them 14 now she
lived in st. Pete Beach Florida yeah
suffice to say mom owned a lot of stuff
right and I had no idea what to do with
any of it so I did what any good son
would do
I called you Hall called u-haul and I
asked the largest truck they had in fact
I needed a one so large I had to wait an
extra day for the 26 foot truck truck to
arrive and as I waited I invited some
mom's friends over to help me deal with
her stuff there's just too much stuff to
go at it alone and I call it the storage
locker and back in Ohio and I asked with
a large largest storage unit they had
and you know what they asked me do you
want one that's climate-controlled I
said that some mom stuff could be
comfortable no I don't want one that's
climate-controlled I just want a big box
of the padlock on it just in case just
in case the three most dangerous words
in the English language and I think
that's really what it boils down to when
we're educating other people is we hold
on to a lot of stuff just in case the LA
Times the one who reported that the
average American household has more than
three hundred thousand items in it but
of course most of us aren't hoarders we
just hold onto a lot of stuff I know my
mom certainly did and so I was packing
up all her stuff and I found these four
boxes that were under her bed as I was
going through all the things and there
were these old printer paper boxes kind
of heavy sealed with excessive amounts
of packing tape so pulled them out from
under the bed one by one and I look down
at each box and I know this sounds like
a bad mystery novel now but I looked at
at the boxes and they were just labeled
one two three four there's my old
elementary school paperwork grades one
through four and all these memories came
rushing back and I realized that mom was
holding onto these boxes because she was
trying to hold onto a piece of me but I
thought to myself wait a minute
mom hadn't opened those boxes in more
than two decades and it became clear to
me in
moment that our memories aren't in our
things our memories are inside us and I
think that's the message that ultimately
allows us to detach from the things that
we give so much meaning to we're
attached to those things because we've
assigned some arbitrary meaning to most
of them and it's not that there's
anything inherently wrong with the stuff
I think the problem is the the meaning
that we tie to those things it prevents
us from letting go but I also say this I
don't think that you can force anyone
one of the questions that someone here
has right now is how can I get my friend
spouse mother daughter to be a
minimalist and and my answer to you is
you can't try to change someone but the
best answer is you can you can show them
the benefits of minimalism when I became
a minimalist I didn't jump up and say
hey look at me I'm becoming a minimalist
at Ryan you should too because you have
a lot of [ __ ] but he did but what that
wouldn't have worked right what worked
was why why are you so happy as yes he
said why the hell are you so happy and
people see the benefits people at work
started saying you seem so much calmer
you seem less stressed what the hell is
going on with you you seem so much nicer
and and then that opened up the door for
me to talk about what I had done for my
life and how I had simplified and how it
wasn't a perfect life but I was walking
in a direction that was in line with my
values my short-term actions were in
line with my long-term values and I
think if we can show that that will show
people the benefits of living a more
simple a more deliberate life
thank you so much for this you're making
me think about so much really about how
it's like you know how we eat also
minimalist
why is how we exercise a lot of
different things but you know there's
one thing about how you live your
personal life but then how about some
discussion on reconciling your
professional life when so many careers
are circling around a consumption and
yeah I often think to myself like what
would happen if like the internet blew
up and you know our books were lost and
we could never find them again it's like
somehow I had to go back and get a
regular job I've often thought about
like how would I approach that and
ultimately I would look for something
that that was in alignment with my
values and beliefs and when I say values
and beliefs I'm talking about like my
health is very important to me my
relationships are very important to me
cultivating passion growing contributing
those are things that I have to focus on
in order to to live a meaningful life
and I would go after something that
would allow me to to focus on those
things specifically like my whole plan
from the beginning when I first
discovered minimalism and I was like oh
yeah if I don't have this huge mortgage
in this brand-new car I don't have to
work 60 or 70 hours a week I could
probably get my bills down to where I
could live off of a like a barista
salary and at the time I just I was
really adamant about getting my time
back so I could focus on those things so
yeah certainly we have to pay the bills
we have to keep the lights on and keep
and keep food in our mouths and you know
it sound like Josh and I just like quit
our jobs and started a blog it took a
lot of work to get to this point and we
worked a lot the difference is that now
the work that we do it is in alignment
with our
and beliefs yeah we just said that don't
follow your passion series I I think
it's shitty advice when someone tells
you to follow your passion you see it
like I'm successor YZ posters and in
self-help books and and stuff because it
presupposes that you have a pre-existing
passion like you were born to be an
astronaut or a yoga instructor or a
writer or a barista or whatever the
truth is there are dozens of things that
you can be passionate about so there
isn't just a passion for you to follow I
think the better advice the more nuanced
advice is well Ryan just said
cultivating your passion so find
something aligns with your values your
interests and then find a way to
cultivate that into a passion and
ultimately there are ways that of course
you can turn that into a living if you
if you want to but but if you have
developed something that is a passion it
may or may not be a route that you want
to take I mean Orion is extremely
passionate about snowboarding in fact
when when you first meet someone what's
the first question they ask you what do
you do it's like what do you mean what
do I do I listen to music I go to
concerts i watch movies oh you're asking
me where do I work how much money do I
make so you can compare you to me on the
socio-economic ladder we just don't ask
the question that way because then we
seem rude right and so instead we just
say what do you do
and then we reset our business business
card title the thing that's on our
business card and and then we spend the
next 10 15 minutes talking about what we
do to earn a paycheck yeah we all need
to earn a paycheck right I mean we all
need to earn money in order to to pay
the bills I think that the key for for
being being more deliberate about about
that is getting getting the bills down
to what is sustainable for us that we're
no longer tied to a particular lifestyle
that forces us to to behave long-term in
ways that are out of sync with our with
our with our values and and so I know
for me this this whole minimalism thing
was a really beautiful accident and I'm
glad it worked out but my initial intent
when I walked away from the corporate
world was gonna write fiction and I was
working to work at the coffee shop two
blocks from my house and no one believed
me
when I was leaving and I was you know
making six-figure salary and they like
were you really going because if anyone
could be a writer than anyone would do
it I'm like wait a minute
I'm not the first person to go down this
path to try to earn a living as a writer
like someone has done this before right
so there is a recipe or a model by which
you know a template that I that I can
try to at least emulate in some way yeah
I guess the only thing that I would add
is I think that there is a lot to say
about the changing environment and where
in which work takes place where it seems
like a lot more companies are being open
to remote work working from home being a
little bit more flexible in terms of
that structure because I think there's a
lot of pressure for people who have
full-time jobs which I would imagine or
most people in this room to dress a
certain way when you're at work which
makes it a little bit harder I mean I
work from home I made this film we made
this film excited in my bedroom but like
usually wearing nothing but I'm not
gonna give you too many details but
t-shirt and jeans let's just say that so
it was a very it's a lot easier I think
when you don't have to go out and
present yourself every single day to
coworkers but I think that the world is
starting to change and people are
becoming more accepting of those kind of
working environments and lifestyles and
that's not [ __ ] you're shaking ahead
what's the I mean I'm well aware of
Right Livelihood so it's a little bit
you know I'm well aware of that but it's
sort of like if you're doing brand work
for instance what I have a lot sort of
difficult to like when the end goal is
something that can is to sell more
products yeah I mean align yourself with
something that it's not causing harm or
not causing more consumption in a way
that's really egregious right yeah thank
you for the question
hi my name is Virginia that was really
great thank you thank you very much
I I was really surprised to see Rick
Hansen I'm really a big fan of his and I
just happened to have started this sort
of Buddhist inquiry about two years ago
because I went to see him speak at Tibet
house down in Chelsea and I just think
he's he's fabulous and I was wondering
kind of saw you know a few Buddhists in
this film and I was wondering kind of
what your connection has been to that
sort of path and if you have sort of
found yourselves sort of becoming more
Buddhist in any way and you know if not
religion at least like lifestyle it's
great because like will be out signing
books in an event and people will come
up to us and they'll be like you know it
is just so nice to see two Christians
going around and spreading the message
of Jesus and we just kind of like smile
and nod like yes and then like a few
people later like it is so nice to see
two young men going out and spreading
the message of Buddha if we get an email
the other day someone was like you know
Muhammad was the original minimalist and
and ultimately I don't know what Matt's
beliefs are Josh and I have very erratic
radically different beliefs when it
comes to spirituality in fact that's why
we don't write about it it's because we
would never agree on anything that we
would write but but I think that's the
beautiful thing about this message and
about this movement is that it's it's
open to all it you could be a Buddhist
you could be an atheist you could be
whatever and and still take some
ingredients away from this because no
matter who you know who we're praying to
or what religion we are this is
certainly benefiting the greater good
there's no doubt about that Matt you
want to talk about religion I would love
to talk about religion my mom's in the
audience so I'm sure she would love to
hear about this he was eight or nine
nineteen siblings yeah
Catholic Catholic family yeah so that
explains that no you actually the other
thing else
about the film is it there were several
do intentionally several different
perspectives and we found this early on
we started going out on the road and we
would have rabbis show up in an event
and we in the film we have Joshua
Becker's a pastor Sam Harris those you
know Sam Harris is a pretty well-known
atheist he wrote the end of faith and
and and so you what we tried to do was
was say that this template is really a
value system right and while Ryan and I
have different beliefs and many of us
have different beliefs there we can we
share the same values at the end of the
day so whether it's Buddhism dan Harris
is a Buddhist he's in the film and and
so whether or not you have one
particular path they all end up in a
pretty similar place in terms of in
terms of our values and and that that's
what's really nice so the people I
surround myself with now we're different
in terms of personalities quite often we
have different interests we certainly
have different beliefs different desires
but but we tend to share similar values
at the end of the day absolutely thanks
again thank you do one more here Sam is
last question has to be outstanding
that's all the matters we just recently
read your book a few months ago and
we're like this is cool it's an actual
thing but when like Christmas comes
around none of our parents or friends
read this book so how do you tell your
friends and family members please don't
buy me crap you just you it's it's a
paradox you have to give them our book
nice job at the upside available for so
open the lobby yeah it's
minimize them minimize our friends and
family night don't write that down I'm
joking no here here well actually you
know what I want to hear what Matt does
because I'm much more draconian actually
I've seen Josh before turn down stuff
and it could get a little cringy where
like somebody's like I made you this
hand bound from leather and I'm like you
should probably take it and he's like no
I'm just gonna leave this here and I'm
gonna leave the room and that happens
but I think but what it is is I think
you have to say no oftentimes I mean
that's what advertising they're trying
to sell you stuff on social media people
are perhaps pushing things that you may
not want but you kind of have this
desire for my girlfriend's mom I met her
she was amazing and then she offered up
three gifts upon meeting her so you have
to choose if those things add value to
my life if I use them if I enjoy them
I'll keep them if not you can regifter
give it to somebody else next Christmas
or hopefully you can get rid of it a
little bit sooner than that but I think
you know there's a lot of ways to go
about it but I certainly wouldn't
suggest keeping it if you're not going
to use it just storing it in your attic
and you know you would want somebody to
get a value from those objects and those
gifts I would also add this beforehand
it's I think it's really about setting
expectations away in advance so it is
May 1st
right now 2016 now is the time is so
talking about Christmas presents or
actually last month or two months ago is
a good time to start just planting these
seeds and setting expectations because
what happens is it's Thanksgiving and
people are like I'm getting ready to go
on Black Friday and buy you a bunch of
stuff you didn't ask for and and and
just try to set the expectations early
on and often enough that it becomes a
pattern over a period of time that
doesn't work really well for me it's
also worked really well for my part in
Rebecca and and I mean her parents look
trying to buy Ella bunches up everyone
tries to buy Ella stuff because you know
she's two and a half and and so by
setting those expectations in advance
but the other way to set that
expectation
to tell them what you don't want but to
tell them what you do want so give me
experiences and sometimes a book can be
an experience going out to a concert
together can be an experience or also
consumables a nice bottle of wine really
great bag of coffee something that you
can enjoy it together is is generally an
experience over over a consumable and
and I think if you set that expectation
upfront people appreciate that because
ultimately why are they buying you the
gift it's because they want to show that
they well that they love you and we've
been we've been sold as a meme that
gift-giving is a love language and I
think that's like saying Pig Latin is a
Romance language I mean the truth is yes
the the the the gesture is love but what
we're doing is trying to say here's this
shiny trinket to to represent that I
don't think that's necessary what I
think is necessary is to show someone
you care every single day and so the
other thing that I do that you may or
may not want to do is I avoid obligatory
gift-giving holidays so I can still
celebrate the holiday season or whatever
but I don't if I get someone a gift and
it can be here I got this for you on May
1st
well what is today it's not my birthday
it's not Christmas yeah because I
thought you'd really find value in this
and I care about you now I want you to
have something gonna find value in and I
didn't feel obligated to give this to
you well doesn't that feel so much
better than oh it's here's the thing I'm
supposed to give you on February 14th
and now you're supposed to give me a
thing and we're gonna compare these two
things and and and then it becomes this
weird obligation of exchange and so I
try to when I give the best gifts they
tend to be on days where I'm not
obligated to do so I'll just say a quick
story when what like after a month of
the website being up my mom called me
and she was like hey son how's it going
like it's going great how you doing
she's like I'm doing well hey what's
this minimalist crap and now I was like
oh you found the website cuz like we
hadn't told anyone she must have been
googling my name and came across it and
she was like so what are you doing like
I mean are you gonna be around for
holidays anymore like you know what's
going on can I give you gifts still can
i buy you
and I said mom I'll definitely be around
for holidays in fact I hope to be around
more because that's about the only time
I saw her during the year was during
holidays I said I really hope I can see
more than just holidays I said but yeah
when it comes to buying me stuff I would
prefer you not to buy me anything and
she was like well I'm your mother and
I'm still gonna buy you stuff I suppose
she has that right as my mother to say
that and I was like well mom if you do
that then I'm gonna have to if I don't
you if I don't use the item that you get
me if I have no use for it I'm gonna
have to find someone else who can get
some benefit from it like I'll have to
give it away or maybe go donate it or
something this is not the thing to tell
your mother by the way she got she got
pretty angry rightfully so though I
guess and we were kind of going back and
forth and eventually I got to a point
where I just felt like it was just
getting out of control and I'm like mom
I love you so much you love me too right
she's like yeah of course I love you
like I want you to be happy you want me
to be happy too right she's like yeah of
course I want you to be happy
and I'm like well if that's the case I
don't I don't need you to be a
minimalist I don't need you to have a
packing party I'm not going to come to
your home and judge the things that you
have in your house
I just need support that's it and that's
what really kind of touched her heart
and I had that conversation over and
over and over again
and she came in to visit visited me and
my girlfriend out in Montana last
February for the first time and we had
like just gotten a new place and she
brought out like these candleholders and
like this how they said she's like so
excited to give these to me and I'm like
you know smiling and hugging her and I'm
like of course I'm not like what are you
bringing me stuff like I'm very you know
being very courteous
um and she was like I really hope you
like this stuff and I hope it fits in
your home but if it doesn't I totally
understand that that you you might have
to give that away she's like but I just
wanted to show you how proud I am of you
and how much I appreciate you for having
me out here it took her four years ago
to that point in and it was it was
like a magical moment and I think having
a conversation similar to that will
really help kind of change the hearts of
your friends and loved ones who are
thank you thank you before we close
things out since we have Matt here and
this is the only one of these he's going
to be at as we go around the country
we're gonna be in Boston in the morning
we wouldn't ask him a couple questions
maybe you guys surprised well maybe we
could talk a little bit about the film
because this is your your first feature
film and and as much time as we spent on
the road we never really got into your
motivations for wanting to do something
like this so would you be willing to
talk to ya about the motivations for
making this know it's funny I saw a
friend Jacob outside and he was saying
we're kind of reminiscing about a
conversation we had which was I guess
about four years ago or so it was a
little bit before we started the film
where he was like man this was your
dream to make a feature-length
documentary and then just to see like I
walked outside and then I see like a
group of 20 people and I'm like half of
my family and I go a lot of people came
out and then I go around the corner and
I just see this line down the block and
I was just blown away I was like this is
crazy because like I said I made this
movie and edited it in my bedroom so I
think what it is now to the entire thing
was filmed in his bedroom exactly
exactly I just must be creepy for
Natalie by the way yeah totally creepy
Natalie wasn't cool with it at all but I
just just to see how we started it I
mean really in terms of filmmaking this
was minimalist filmmaking at its finest
and we had a very minimalist budget of
zero dollars to make this film we we
literally just went into this thing with
just a lot of passion to one of
materialize this project and really
without an idea of how it was going to
come together in the end like one of my
favorite quotes is from another
filmmaker
said that if your story doesn't change
along the way then you weren't listening
and that's something that I think really
rang true with this film like we started
out and we interviewed with a lot of
people that gave their personal stories
it was very anecdotal and and which was
amazing and you get to see these people
like a jelly on which like just every
time I see that scene with AJ who is the
the Wall Street broker it's just I'm so
enthralled and I'm like this dude is a
genius and I just want to listen to him
for an hour but then we started to
interview other people that it wasn't
just about personal it was let's take a
step back and let's talk to it with
Juliet Shore and Colin Beavan and and
why are we here and and kind of how we
got to this point as a society and as a
culture and I feel still think it's
something we're figuring out and I think
it's something that's changing very
quickly as you see movements like
minimalism growing but just I think that
just to go back to that quote it's about
looking at what you're gathering along
the way and continually changing and
figuring it out and like Josh was saying
in the beginning there were changes like
we had this film festival cut and it was
great and we literally had a standing
ovation the first time we screened it so
at that point and at that point I knew I
wanted to make changes to the film and I
had talked to them about that before
then and then they got the standing
ovation and I was like I'm never gonna
be able make the changes I want to make
to the film and then you know I just
kept pushing them a little bit and I was
like guys I think I think we can do a
little bit better I think that there are
certain changes that we can make to
expand this film and to expand the
region to kind of tie this narrative
together in a more cohesive way and we
went back and forth and I would say you
know it took a while before we were all
in the same page before we could all I
mean it Josh you said something about
like the different peaks and it's like
you have to be able to just like
minimalism listen to other people's
feedback and there's another quote where
it's I think it's like an African
proverb where you can go fast alone but
you go far together so if I just did
this all by myself and didn't listen to
any other feedback I don't think we we
definitely would have gotten this final
product we would have gotten to where we
are so I think it took an entire group
to come together
to really make it what it is I can I
have two words you can choose which
question you want to answer um I get
asked this question all the time
and every time I get asked them like I
wonder what Matt would say people always
ask me like what's your biggest learning
experience through this this documentary
actually just answer that one questions
here now I would say I gave you a
specific example of when we were filming
I would say like the the the biggest
thing I have is questioning assumptions
I remember we were in Albuquerque and
this is like really just as small it
seems like a very micro almost like an
important event in terms of the entire
documentary but Josh went up to the roof
of our hotel and he's like Matt you can
go up there there's a great shot you can
get it like a time-lapse of the sunset
so I went out there and I shot it and I
would love to get a shot this the
sunrise over the beautiful Albuquerque
Mountains and there was this big hotel
room the the biggest building in
Albuquerque blocking the view I was like
I guess I can't get it I was like wow
why don't I go over to the hotel and ask
him if I can actually first of all I
went up to the roof because I think
don't ask permission first just try to
do it but the door was locked to the
roof so I asked the concierge I said hey
do you mind if I come in five in the
morning and shoot a sunrise on your
building and she's like let me text my
boss let me text my manager I was like
okay this is definitely not gonna happen
because you could just be like no that's
the weirdest thing so then I waited
there for 45 minutes and she's like yeah
he said you can come in the engineer
will let you up onto the roof so I went
up with the engineer at 5:00 a.m. in the
morning he came in early for me
open the door he's like don't jump off
and then he closed the door and then he
left me there for three or four hours
where I just filmed this a mate well
actually I mean it was a beautiful
sunrise it didn't come up that well the
time-lapse kind of sucked but I think
what that taught me is to just question
your assumptions you kind of you may not
think that your boss is going to give
you the raise or the promotion so you
don't ask for it and I think that that's
something I learned and that's something
that just minimalism in general has
taught me is they're just question
assumptions don't just go with the
grooves of how you think life is
unfold and kind of pave your own way
your own path awesome I want to thank a
few people before before we get out of
here first off we it costs a lot of
money for us to go on the road like this
and so our friends over at a company
called Blue Host they host our website
and we when we first started a blog we
couldn't even spell HTML and and so they
they've helped us out a lot over the
years and they helped pay just for our
travel and to make it out here so I just
want to say thanks to Bluehost if you
give them a round of applause I really
appreciate it
also this seriously wouldn't be possible
without the guy who produces our podcast
does all our operations does everything
on the back end
Shawn Harding is back there in the
darkness where he always is give him a
round of applause he is the
hardest-working man in middle minimalism
for sure and I think most important I
really want to thank you all for for
coming out here tonight and being
willing to to stick out with a stick out
throughout all of this we're gonna be
out there afterward we'll we'll do some
photos we have some books out there if
you forgot your wallet or don't have
enough money right now you're welcome to
grab a book Shawn will be out there
selling them as well but if you don't
have the money for right now that's okay
you're walking though to pick one up on
us and well should we alright we'll be
out there and oh grab a hug obviously
right you you know they're free and
transferable you saw that in the film
and we've gotten much better after tens
of thousands of hugs
so yeah the hugs in the film were not up
to par and now I feel like you know I
understand the science of hugging so so
feel free to to grab one of those we
will be out there and of course if you
leave here with one message we hope it's
this love people and use things the
opposite never works thanks so much for
coming out thank you thank you
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
feeling that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
you